[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bienvenue dans ces idées qui gouvernent
le monde nous allons vous parler de la
psychiatrie le naufrage de la
psychiatrie la psychiatrie sous toutes
ses formes mais elles sont nombreuses
car on ne réduit pas la santé mentale à
un algorithme neuropsychologique cette
psychiatrie donc se porte mal les
difficultés rencontrées par la
psychiatrie sont d'une part les mêmes
que celles qui affecte la médecine
manque de moyens engorgement desservices
fuite vers le privé rémunération
insuffisante perte d'attractivité
asymétrie territoriale avec son appel
les déserts psychiatriques nous
observons aussi un déclin spécifique de
la psychiatrie qui date de la fin des
années 90 avec une stigmatisation de la
santé mentale d'où les politiques ne
sont pas sans reproche de
l'uniformisation impossible de cette
discipline qui fait appel le temps à la
création à l'imagination à l'écoute
analytique à la science à la pharmacopée
on a bien souvent fabriqué un monstre
bureaucratique de surveillance psychique
qui n'est pas adapté aux réalités
terrarium et encore moins opérationnel
dans un contexte social dégradé ou
s'accumule les misères qui ont non
dépression
schizophrénie burnout suicide bref tous
les exilés de l'intime tous les exclus
de la société nous allons en parler avec
mes invités Daniel zaguri vous êtes
psychiatre expert près de la cour
d'appel de Paris Franck Bélivier vous
êtes psychiatre également délégué
ministériel à la santé mentale et à la
psychiatrie Jean de kervas Douai vous
êtes ancien directeur général des
hôpitaux vous êtes à l'Académie des
technologies Marie GI vous êtes
psychiatre et psychanalyste
[Musique]
alors comment sont par l'actualité un
point d'abord sur le manque de soignants
et ce qu'on appelle les désherbes
psychiatriques pourquoi et comment
Daniel zagory
alors
ça c'est une question ce qui c'est une
question essentielle pourquoi cette
désaffection pour une discipline qui est
somptueuse pour une spécialité médicale
qui est magnifique pourquoi est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui nous voyons des des
jeunes psychiatres de la quarantaine qui
étaient taillées pour le service public
qui sont pris dans des conflits éthiques
et qui et qui et qui quittent qui quitte
l'hôpital pour s'installer pour ne pas
avoir honte de ce qu'ils font pour
pouvoir se regarder dans la glace
pourquoi est-ce qu'on en est arrivé à
une telle situation avec une perte
d'attractivité de du choix de la
psychiatrie pour les internes puisque en
termes votre activité la psychiatrie est
40e sur 44 spécialités médicales ce qui
pour quelqu'un de ma génération
est tout à fait
impensable spécialité tiers-monde c'est
une effectivement c'est une spécialité
sinistrée pour vraiment toute une série
de raisons
congruente malheureusement
votre point de vue j'allais dire
officiel monsieur bélier là-dessus les
chiffres nous disent d'abord enfin je
pense qu'il y a un premier facteur
important c'est le la démographie
médicale nous sommes là dans un grand
creux et la relève c'est-à-dire les
jeunes médecins informés ne suffisent
pas à pallier ce manque lié au départ
nous sommes d'ailleurs à la fin de ce
creux puisque 2023 et l'année où la
décrue s'interrompt avant une remontée
jusqu'en 2025 mais la relève n'est pas
là c'est en fait et les territoires qui
sont les plus en difficulté par ce
manque de relève sont les territoires
qui sont de je dirais structurellement
le plus en tension alors il faut
s'entendre aussi sur ce qu'on appelle un
désert médical le premier désert médical
de France c'est le 93 il est à nos
portes c'est-à-dire si on définit un
désert médical comme le l'inadéquation
la plus importante entre les besoins et
l'offre et évidemment les réponses à
apporter à ces types de territoire là je
pense au 93 et bien sont pas du tout les
mêmes que l'autre acception qu'on a du
terme de désert médical qui sont les
grands territoires ruraux et où là
évidemment le le lorsque la pénurie se
fait sentir il y a un cercle vicieux qui
s'installe le travail devient pénible
pour ceux qui restent et parce que la
relève n'est pas là et or il y a quand
même des larges territoires à couvrir
alors est-ce que Jean de kervas Doué on
peut dire que la psychiatrie a les mêmes
problèmes que la médecine mais en plus
grave oui parce qu'il y a une raison
générale et des raisons spécifiques la
raison générale
elle est simple à dire en quelques
chiffres on est passé de 8700 médecins
en numéro exclusius dans les années 70 à
entre 95 et 2000 donc comme on recrute
les jeunes médecins à 19 ans
les gens qui ont 40 45 ans c'est des
gens du creux de la vague des années des
années 90 puisque c'est à l'âge 40 ans
45 ans où on devient chef de service et
on s'aperçoit qu'il n'existe pas alors
il y a par ailleurs un deuxième problème
c'est que et on en reparlera je pense
c'est qu'on a voulu normaliser la
psychiatrie c'est-à-dire que il y avait
autrefois d'ailleurs c'est efficace à
traiter les seuls mais ça salarié
avant la réforme des pH et des
professeurs d'université et c'est
praticiens hospitalier et et
il y a eu au cours de psychiatrie depuis
4 qui était un concours spécifique alors
le problème aujourd'hui on voit ça c'est
ce que disait Daniel zaguri dans le
choix des spécialités à l'internat à mon
avis on devient pas psychiatre parce
qu'on n'a pas réussi et de chirurgien
donc donc un vrai problème de la
politique menée depuis une trentaine
d'années qui a fait disparaître les mots
spécifiques sur la psychiatrie la santé
mentale en prétendant que c'était une
spécialité comme les autres
et ça c'est le problème essentiel et
puis troisième et dernier problème c'est
que il y a d'énormes variations en
général puisque il y a des secteurs
psychiatriques qui n'ont pas de
psychiatre et les variations de moyens
entre secteurs psychiatriques varie de 1
à 10 ce qui est absolument considérable
et ce qui est encore beaucoup plus que
dans les autres secteurs de la médecine
alors Marie jaccardi vous avez
l'avantage si on peut dire d'être
psychiatre psychanalyse de terrain et
veut dire dans quelles conditions vous
travaillez est-ce que vous constatez que
ce numerus clausus crée des situations
de pénurie et j'aimerais avec vous
avoir une réponse à une préoccupation
forte aujourd'hui
en ce qui concerne les urgences est-ce
qu'il est exact que c'est un parcours du
combattant pour pouvoir se soigner oui
absolument c'est ce qu'on constate sur
le terrain
d'abord pour aller pour donner quelques
explications peut-être au manque
d'attractivité la spécialité c'est il
faut rappeler que c'est une discipline
très singulière
qui demande des capacités de résistance
au paradigme de notre société à savoir
que elle repose sur un savoir qui se
construit uniquement dans la relation
avec le patient et dans l'espace inter
subjectif
donc cela se heurte les paradis d'un
société tôt c'est-à-dire que il faut
avoir on a affaire une part
d'incertitude
quotidienne et il faut donc pouvoir
supporter cette part d'incertitude
puisque c'est une spécialité purement
clinique aucun moyen de prouver le
diagnostic en établi qui s'établit juste
dans l'inter-surtivité et ça n'a rien à
voir avec le discours de l'évidence
baise médecine dans laquelle nous sommes
baignés et pendant nos études et pendant
notre exercice nous nous trouvons pas
prouver ce que nous avons sont et
d'autre part nous travaillons dans un
espace-temps qui est très différent et
qui doit nous décaler de la course folle
que nous vivons dans la société actuelle
puisque le temps psychique est un temps
long il faut du temps pour rencontrer le
patient instaurer un climat de confiance
comprendre ce qui se passe où va se
loger sa souffrance et nous ne pouvons
pas donc assurer que nous devons
expliquer d'emblée et à sa famille que
nous n'allons pas avoir un résultat
immédiat nous n'allons pas avoir une
efficacité médiane non ça n'ira pas
mieux demain en ce qui concerne le
parcours du combattant oui c'est un
parcours du combattant d'abord parce
qu'il y a une détérioration une
dégradation de la santé mentale mais qui
est en période à la crise de la pandémie
on y reviendra certainement
et donc il y a certes une pénurie de
psychiatres mais il y a une explosion
des demandes de soi qui avoir cette
dégradation de la santé mentale qui fait
que nous avons à peu près trois à enfin
les personnes qui sont en demande
attendent parfois 3 à 6 mois avant de
pouvoir rencontrer un psychiatre que
lorsqu'un psychiatre s'installe en
cabinet privé son cabinet est plein en
un mois et pour qu'il s'occupe bien de
sa passion de telle il doit refuser les
nouvelles demandes ou bien encore pire
faire le tri des demandes entre selon
des critères d'urgence et notamment
le risque suicidaire qui est majeur dans
la population actuelle et qui touche
surtout les jeunes de 11 à 25 ans vous
travaillez je travaille en clinique je
travaille dans deux endroits en clinique
privée dans une institution
privée d'hospitalisation de Senlis et
mon cabinet de consultation alors
Monsieur bélier je m'intéresse ce jour à
vous sur la question de la formation les
psychiatres et les infirmiers
psychiatriques avaient l'habitude de
travailler ensemble aujourd'hui à vous
écouter
la psychiatrie n'est plus une spécialité
médicale mais on va former pendant deux
ans si je si mon information est bonne
des informe des infirmiers en pratique
avancées autant dire que la santé
mentale et dans un trou là alors en
termes de personnel juste un commentaire
sur ce que ma collègue vient de dire
avant la crise covid les suivis
épidémiques de la population française
ne montrait pas une dégradation de la
santé mentale des Français en revanche
on a vu ces 10 20 dernières années un
nombre croissant de demandes converger
vers la psychiatrie ce qui est plutôt
une bonne nouvelle c'est à dire que la
réticence a sollicité une aide
psychologique ou une aide médicale
psychiatrique et bien c'est atténué et
la démarche de d'aller voir un
psychologue ou un psychiatre c'est
démocratisé c'est devenu plus facile la
crise covid a clairement
épidémiologiquement sur l'ensemble de la
population française montrer une
dégradation des indicateurs de
dépression d'anxiété de troubles du
sommeil et d'idées suicidaires je
réponds à votre question
la formation des des la démarche de
formation des infirmiers en pratique
avancées spécialisés en santé mentale
vise à satisfaire cette idée de face à
la pénurie de psychiatre à
faciliter une délégation de tâches en
direction d'infirmiers qui ont reçu
spécifiquement une formation pour
recevoir cette délégation de tâches donc
ce n'est ce n'est ça je pense que ça va
enrichir le le parcours de santé mentale
des patients qui ont besoin d'une
continuité donc ça va l'enrichir alors
là le problème c'est qu'il manque à la
fois des psychiatres et on va former des
infirmiers mais ça va prendre quelques
années et comment on va faire là
maintenant alors si on a un
embouteillage psychique si je peux
utiliser cette expression triviale alors
on court on court un peu après cette
inadéquation entre les besoins et
l'offre ça c'est clairement le cas et
c'est pas les infirmiers de pratiques
avancées qui seront quelques milliers
dans quelques années mais qui
aujourd'hui sont quelques centaines en
santé mentale donc effectivement c'est
pas c'est pas une c'est plutôt une
réponse moyen terme qu'une réponse long
terme je veux pas vous taquiner mais je
voudrais me demander à Monsieur zaguri
quand vous entendez monsieur belivier
dire qu'il y a une inadéquation entre
l'offre et la demande ça veut dire la
psychiatrie rentre dans un champ
économique et elle est dévoyée de sa
vocation non
c'est pas je cherche pas la polémique
mais est-ce que vous pensez pas qui a là
quelque chose de je crois que c'est très
important que les psychiatres justement
qui font qui sont dans une discipline
extrêmement hétérogène extrêmement
diversifié extrêmement riche mais c'est
à la fois leur talon d'Achille et leur
richesse et c'est très important et je
peux que les les psychiatres quel que
soit le courant qui représente
soit unitaire et est une défense de la
profession il y a pas de pic de la
Mirandole psychiatre qui sache tout la
psychiatrie biologie que l'épidémiologie
la relation la psychanalyse c'est pas
vrai ça n'existe pas mais
tous nous sommes au service d'une
psychiatrie intégrative qui est pour le
patient et qui utilise toutes les
ressources de la connaissance dans
l'intérêt de ce patient donc moi j'ai
pas du tout un esprit polémique et si
vous avez lu mon livre vous avez vu que
ça me paraît extrêmement
important et pas polémique mais vous
dites qu'on massacre la psychiatrie
quand même massacre la psychiatrie parce
que quand vous alors je je dis ça à deux
niveaux au niveau d'une part des
chiffres au niveau bon qui démontrable
et au niveau de ma carrière de mon
parcours au moment où j'ai pris ma
retraite hospitalière en essayant de
comprendre pourquoi j'ai commencé dans
l'enthousiasme et pourquoi j'ai fini
dans cette espèce de marasme alors vous
parliez du 93 tout à l'heure moi de
travailler dans le 9 3 toute ma carrière
et effectivement mais dans le 9 3 il y
avait des psychiatres particulièrement
dynamiques et qui ont fait une
psychiatrie de secteur particulièrement
active et et et à la fin de mon parcours
j'ai pu voir des choses inimaginables
c'est-à-dire la pénurie c'est-à-dire le
recours exagéré à l'isolement et à la
contention c'est-à-dire une bureaucratie
totalement écrasante
beaucoup de choses
une petite précision
je m'adresse à vous aussi comme c'est
que vous êtes un économiste de la santé
quelle part l'économie
par exemple paiement à l'acte
dans l'avocat de la psychiatrie quelle
part l'économie a dans le développement
de la psychiatrie
je ne vais pas répondre tout de suite à
cette question je vais simplement lever
à lièvre qui n'est pas évident pour les
gens qui nous écoutent
mais qui est évident entre nous c'est
que il y a à l'intérieur du monde de la
santé mentale des débats
épistémologiques et théoriques qui sont
violents ce que dit Daniel zaguri
clairement est-ce que vous dites aussi
monsieur c'est qu'il faudrait que tout
le monde travaille ensemble comme c'est
le cas dans le domaine du cancer ou
radiothérapeute chirurgien et médecins
travaillent ensemble et il y a à
l'intérieur du monde de la psychiatrie
des querelles d'écoles qui sont qui
posent des problèmes
alors
la France et vous allez voir que c'est
paradoxal ce que je veux dire la France
est le pays de l'OCDE 40 pays riches
qui dépense le plus pour la santé
mentale en pourcentage de ces dépenses
de santé donc la France dépense 15%
de ses dépenses de santé en santé
mentale la moyenne de le CD que tu
aimerais bien c'est 6,7
alors où est la différence où est
l'erreur elle est dans la prescription
des psychotropes par les généralistes
c'est-à-dire l'essentiel de ce que l'on
compte dans les dépenses de santé
mentale c'est pas le fonctionnement des
secteurs psychiatriques
c'est pas la médecine libérale c'est pas
des consultations ce sont les
prescriptions
la deuxième la deuxième remarque
économique c'est que tout ce qui a été
dit par jusqu'à présent c'est que
effectivement la psychiatrie manque de
moyens à organisation inchangée donc
comme nous avons en stock beaucoup
d'argent vous avez en France aussi en
valeur absolue et pas relativement de
psychiat beaucoup plus que la plupart
des pays occidentaux
c'est que donc nous avons un problème
collectif d'organisation que nous
refusons de regarder et que
toutes choses étant égale par ailleurs
c'est à dire que les deux discours sont
vraies quand vous dites on manque de
moyens c'est vrai on manque de moyens
parce que les l'augmentation des
dépenses
en psychiatrie a été très inférieure à
l'inflation et pour goût d'autres
considérations donc les secteurs
psychiatriques ont eu de moins en moins
d'argent simplement collectivement de
dépensons beaucoup d'argent donc la
conclusion c'est que il faudrait que
collectivement et cette émission nous
aide on regarde au problème
d'organisation
[Musique]
un peu d'histoire après la deuxième
guerre mondiale nous avons observé une
prise de conscience collective
pour humaniser la psychiatrie et la
sortie si on peut dire de cette
concentration asilaire
est-ce qu'on assiste à un retour en
arrière aujourd'hui
à travers la bureaucratisation des
pratiques à travers la stigmatisation de
la santé mentale
vous avez raison
partons de 1945 partant de la prière il
y a eu quelque chose tout à fait
exceptionnel qui était la convergence
d'une sensibilité collective plus jamais
ça plus jamais l'univers
concentrationnel de
d'un certain nombre de personnes dans la
haute administration française et de
jeunes psychiatres qui ont mis en place
la psychothérapie institutionnelle et
puis ensuite le secteur c'est-à-dire que
vous avez eu tout un mouvement
convergent de désaliénisme qui
est qu'on va retrouver avec le secteur
et avec la psychiatrie de ma génération
enfin quand j'ai commencé la psychiatrie
dans l'enthousiasme c'est-à-dire que
nous avions un système de santé et nous
avons pu vérifier sur le terrain ça fait
condité quand
[Musique]
et ça c'est quelque chose qui s'est
perdu est-ce que Marie jaccardi vous
constatez dans votre exercice
cette éparpillement c'est à dire la non
convergence entre une approche
thérapeutique classique la psychanalyse
la neuropsychiatrie est-ce que ça se
défait cette chose-là alors ça ça a été
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec vous
ça a été très vrai jusqu'à maintenant
c'est à dire que nous avons tous
fonctionné un peu prisonnier ou dans le
dogme de nos champs de sa voix la
psychanalyse les sciences comme qu'il
faut comportementales les neurosciences
et autres en se livrant des guéguères et
en essayant de de faire passer notre
champ de Savoie comme le dogme de ceux
qui allaient le mieux soigner la
personne maintenant bien obligé de
fonctionner différemment et tant mieux
c'est à dire qu'il va falloir penser
la santé mentale avec le primat du lien
à savoir que ça va être au-delà du
colloque singulier médecin malade
l'idée c'est d'identifier et de
rassembler
les relations ressources qu'il existe
autour de la personne et de faire
travailler ensemble plusieurs
professionnels de la santé mentale parce
que nous ne sommes pas heureusement les
psychiatres les seuls acteurs de la
santé mentale et donc pour expliquer
plus clairement et brièvement prenons la
métaphore du filet de Norbert Elias
comment est formé un filet chacun des
fils est une unité en soi et ce qui va
faire la structure du filet c'est la
façon dont sont tissés les fils entre
eux et il est devenu maintenant
impératif de penser les choses comme ça
sur un maillage collectif d'un ensemble
d'intervenants en santé mentale et je
loue tout à fait moi la création de la
profession d'infirmiers de pratiques
avancées je reçois dans mon cabinet en
stage le mois prochain une infirmière de
pratique avant c'est parce que vous ont
besoin de faire des stages parce qu'ils
vont pouvoir enrichir notre discipline
certes des obstruer les urgences mais
ils pourront intervenir à beaucoup de
niveaux mais dans ce tissage en fait où
le psychiatre va peut-être devenir alors
un coordinateur de soin puisque leur
pratique en santé mentale vous le savez
va reposer sur un contrat avec le
psychiatre donc le psychiatre
coordonnera les soins mais ça se passera
il faut il faut on en est plus à la
division de toute façon c'est trop grave
donc il faut c'est le soir
on va demander votre avis monsieur
Bélivier sur ce tissage très sage est-ce
qu'on est conscient au niveau des
pouvoirs publics qu'il faut intégrer les
innovations les expérimentations parce
que c'est pas j'allais dire c'est pas
une discipline ordinaire elle nécessite
toute l'imagination la science l'analyse
etc et est-ce que vous facilitez cette
chose là alors deux réponses à votre
question la première à ces personnel qui
est moi je me reconnais dans ce qui
vient d'être dit je pense que c'est ces
guerres théoriques sont un peu derrière
nous en tout cas j'appartiens à une
génération de psychiatres qui a fait
l'intégration de ces différents savoirs
et qui font d'ailleurs toute la richesse
de la formation des psychiatres et je
pense que c'est vrai pour la génération
qui arrive ils ont réussi à faire
l'intégration de ces différents courants
de penser de techniques
psychothérapiques et situer l'acte
médical un peu à la au carrefour de ces
différents savoirs donc je pense que
c'est au contraire aujourd'hui quelque
chose qui doit être revendiqué comme une
richesse de cette discipline au niveau
des pouvoirs publics on est à théoriques
on n'est pas une société savante le
ministère de la santé n'est pas une
société savante
[Musique]
qui se déliterait en fait je pense que
il faut il faut d'abord rappeler que
la doctrine promule les les
piliers de de la de la loi de secteur
n'ont pas pris une ride aujourd'hui vous
retrouvez les grands principes promus
par la loi de secteur dans la feuille de
route sans démonter les psychiatrie
promotion à l'ambulatoire les malades
dans la cité etc etc
mais ce qu'il faut entendre c'est que le
terme secteur en réalité recouvre trois
choses c'est d'abord un territoire et ce
territoire il a beaucoup bougé depuis
les années 60 même si la loi de secteur
a été confirmée en 90 aujourd'hui les
patients ne sont plus captifs d'un
territoire dans au sein d'un territoire
il y a le l'acteur principal n'est plus
que le secteur il y a des territoires où
il y a des il y a des une offre non
sectorisée privée public qui fait que
les patients doivent aussi s'y retrouver
là-dedans deuxièmement le terme secteur
c'est c'est un projet c'est un projet
dont le chef de service de secteur avait
la maîtrise et
il avait à concevoir son projet de soins
pour les pour les malades dont il avait
la responsabilité et ce sans référence
obligatoire au références de aux
recommandations de bonnes pratiques ou
aux données probantes en tout cas ces
recommandations de drague elles n'ont
jamais été opposable
troisièmement le secteur c'est une
organisation et en fonction de des
politiques portées par les ARS et par
les établissements on a vu naître c'est
les agences régionales de santé on a vu
naître des différences d'un
établissement un autre et d'une région à
une autre et de tout cela il résulte
aujourd'hui une somme de particularisme
qui sont peu lisibles et je pense que
les réformes que nous portons visent au
ministère de la Santé vise à remettre un
petit peu d'ordre dans tout ça
serait parfait si on arrivait dans le
meilleur des mondes mais c'est pas
forcément le cas quand on regarde la
psychiatrie alors c'est pas que je veux
entrer dans des contradictions
polémiques mais sur un plan politique
Jean de kervas Douai
sous le gouvernement
de Nicolas Sarkozy alors président de la
République et de Madame Bachelot à
l'époque
responsable de la santé
une certaine confusion s'est opérée
entre santé mentale délinquance
criminalité
est-ce que c'est ce qui a entraîné une
judiciarisation de la psychiatrie et ce
qu'il a éloigné de ses rails
thérapeutiques
et qui peut expliquer le désenchantement
de Monsieur zaguri aujourd'hui Daniel en
parlerait beaucoup aux aguerris en
parlerait beaucoup mieux que moi de ça
mais la loi du 5 juillet 2011 est un
drame
parce que elle fait l'hypothèse que les
malades mentaux sont certains malades
mentaux sont des tueurs en puissance et
ça ça va contrôler c'est ici comme ça
ne tue pas plus les autres sauf à
l'intérieur de leur famille donc
des familles la criminalité et donc ça
ça conduit à des procédures folles qui
prennent du temps administratif qui
prennent du temps infirmier et qui font
d'ailleurs que ces mesures ne sont pas
respectées parce qu'elles ne sont pas
respectables au sens des moyens en
personnel qu'il faudrait pour
l'inspecter autant du côté des tribunaux
que du côté des services de psychiatrie
donc tout ça me paraît absolument
dramatique bon je pense je suis pas
certain que nos
gens qui nous écoutent
sont bien conscients des différentes
armes thérapeutiques à la définition
d'un secteur donc je vais juste en dire
un mot pour être et pour expliquer parce
que un secteur psychiatrique c'est pas
seulement c'est pas seulement délit
c'est
des des lits de jour des lits de nuit
des consultations des centres médicaux
pédagogiques et ces arbres il y a toute
une série de gammes sur lesquels un
secteur peut jouer et visiblement il y
en a qui jouent mieux que d'autres et le
problème de la politique c'est de faire
en sorte que tout le monde joue à peu
près bien donc et on en est on en est
relativement loin parce qu'il y a pas
d'armes il y a pas de flamme si vous
voulez vous n'entend vous n'avez jamais
entendu ça c'est une remarque générale
et je vais m'arrêter là mais
une chose qui me frappe en repensant sur
un peu plus de 50 ans de politique de
santé dans ce pays c'est que les partis
politiques ne parlent jamais
d'organisation des gens c'est parti
politique ne parle uniquement que
d'accès des gens à la médecine et
notamment le ticket modérateur le
financement etc mais vous avez pas un
engagement d'un parti politique sur la
santé mentale à ma connaissance vous
n'avez pas un engagement sur le drame de
ce que vit aujourd'hui la médecine
libérale et on va voir ça avec les
problèmes de convention et le drame de
ce qui se passe à l'hôpital pas
uniquement psychiatrique mais les autres
mais je crois que Daniel est beau
monsieur vous êtes plus mieux adapté
pour parler de la loi 2011 moi justement
Daniel Zagori cette loi de 2011
qui a fait un qui a tressé peut-être pas
un lien mais en tout cas
une direction entre délinquance et
psychiatrie elle a encore des
conséquences aujourd'hui
évidemment alors vous avez prononcé le
nom d'un président de la République qui
a effectivement
stigmatisé
les malades mentaux
que peut que peut signifier une
politique d'État de déstigmatisation
quand le président de la République
lui-même stigmatise les malades mentaux
en associant criminalité et délinquance
et en instrumentalisant tout au long de
son quinquennat des faits divers au
point d'ailleurs que il y a quelque
chose d'assez étonnant que dont je me
suis rendu compte quand j'ai écrit mon
livre c'est que la psychiatrie en France
c'est dans les médias c'est les services
police justice mais le service Santé de
temps en temps
ils font un très bon un très bon
reportage mais mais ça va pas plus loin
et en définitive c'est pas ça qui qui
est qui est central donc il y a eu en
effet durant le quinquennat de Nicolas
Sarkozy d'une part la loi HPST c'est le
directeur qui commande et
directeur étant un administratif voilà
et c'est comme ça et qui nous a fait
perdre une une quinzaine une quinzaine
d'années c'est ce que disait un ancien
ministre de la Santé récemment dans le
monde il y a eu donc la loi HPST il y a
eu la loi de 2011 qui est une loi
bureaucratique est une loi de
stigmatisation qui n'a pas du tout été
discuté avec les psychiatres la loi de
l'ancienne loi de 1838 a été discuté
avec les aliénistes pendant un an et
demi donc là elle a été imposée contre
les contre les psychiatres donc et vous
avez donc
cette cette loi de 2011 cette loi
HPST et
donc ça effectivement été un
accélérateur un accélérateurs
vous êtes expert auprès de la Cour
d'appel et vous êtes très connu
d'ailleurs pour votre sabbaticité dans
ce domaine mais quelquefois vous avez
des personnes atteintes de troubles
mentaux qui se livrent à des actes
délinquants ça peut arriver bon et là on
vous soumet ces cas-là
la société est faite de ces faits divers
qui existent etc
comment on peut faire pour rassurer les
opinions publiques comme vous le savez
bien qui sont inquiets dès qu'il y a un
crime ou on l'a vu récemment avec un
acteur célèbre
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire là à ce
niveau là ce qu'il faut faire d'abord
c'est un travail d'objectivation
savez-vous quel est le pourcentage des
schizophrènes qui tu
ent oui mais il suffit d'aller que ce
soit médiatisé vous avez bien l'opinion
publique savez-vous le pourcentage des
schizophrènes qui ne tue pas c'est
99,70% d'accord donc on peut pas
stigmatiser une catégorie de patients
du fait de d'un rapport avec la
criminalité
et la deuxième réponse qui me paraît la
réponse la plus importante c'est que
meilleur sera le dispositif de santé
publique moins il y aura ce type de
de passage à l'acte criminel lié à une
affection psychiatrique donc et si vous
voulez l'une des raisons qui font que la
psychiatrie n'est pas une spécialité
comme les autres c'est justement ce lien
dans l'opinion publique entre violence
et psychiatrie entre crimes et
psychiatrie lien qu'il faut
effectivement dont il faut dire dans
quelle mesure objectivement il existe et
dans quelle mesure il n'existe pas et
lien effectivement qu'il faut
contrecarrer par un dispositif la
réponse la plus rationnelle c'est ayant
le meilleur dispositif de soins et ce
type de problème
sera diminuée alors Franck bel et bien
j'aimerais avoir votre avis sur cette
fameuse loi de 2011 et en même temps en
même temps
on les prisons les prisons sont pleines
de malades mentaux et la rue et là et la
rue aussi alors quelle
est la politique de santé mentale
au regard de ce qui se passe dans nos
prisons
et de ce qui se passe comme bien de dire
Jean de kervas doué dans la rue où il y
a beaucoup de malades d'abord sur la
stigmatisation des malades mentaux et où
la désignation des malades mentaux comme
bouc émissaire d'un certain nombre de
fantasmes sociétaux c'est en réalité une
vieille histoire quand un président de
la République met son grain de sel dans
cette affaire évidemment les
représentations se trouvent encore
renforcées là où au contraire on essaye
de déconstruire ces représentations du
malade mental dangereux puisque les
chiffres sont quand même éloquents
les malades mentaux les malades mentaux
sont beaucoup plus victimes que auteur
si on reprend les données les données
factuelles et que j'insiste sur les
chiffres qui a donné Daniel zaguri c'est
une c'est moins de 1% de patients
schizophrène qui commettent toujours un
jour au cours de leur vie un acte
médico-légal et quand on prend le
problème dans l'autre sens quel est le
pourcentage d'acte médicaux légaux
pénalement répréhensible qui sont commis
par des personnes
ultérieurement reconnu comme porteuse
d'un troubleps psychique c'est pareil
c'est moins d'un pour cent donc quel que
soit l'angle par lequel on prenne le
problème
cette l'effet contredit s'est
représentations et donc il faut lutter
activement pour déstigmatiser ces
représentations et c'est d'ailleurs un
des axes qu'est-ce qu'on fait le
concernant s'agissant des de l'inflation
puisque là on a des données il y a eu
plusieurs enquêtes qui ont montré
qu'effectivement le nombre de de
personnes porteuses d'un trouble
psychique incarcéré est augmentent cons
probablement alors c'est là aussi c'est
un phénomène complexe et qui a plusieurs
facteurs ayant contribué et la
pénalisation des malades mentaux est un
des aspects parce qu'il y a une
évolution quand même dans le dans
l'attitude des juges et dans
les manières d'appliquer le les peines
ou de prendre en compte les certains
degrés de irresponsabilités je pense
qu'on a eu également un effet des
constats psychiatriques immédiats
qui ont globalement disparu on peut dire
je me tourne vers Daniel zaguri et qui
fait opérer un premier filtre
et qui soustrayait un certain nombre de
personnes objectivement malades de
l'instruction
et pour ces personnes dont l'instruction
se poursuivait pour un certain nombre
d'entre eux ça se terminait
effectivement en prison et on se
retrouve avec donc des des
un nombre croissant de malades mentaux
en prison ce qui pose deux questions le
premier c'est l'organisation des soins
en prison dans un contexte de pénurie
parce qu'on a aussi là encore
un point d'inadéquation entre les
besoins des personnes emprison et
l'offre que l'on peut mettre en face et
puis deuxièmement il y a tout l'enjeu
des sortants de prison pour
dire qu'il faut créer des hôpitaux
psychiatriques
qui soit en lien avec les prisons ce que
je suis en train de dire c'est que oui
il des moyens de supplémentaires sont
nécessaires pour les équipes soignantes
qui interviennent en prison ça c'est
très important et puis après il faut il
faut décider des priorités et je pense
que une des priorités qu'on essaye de
soutenir
c'est des dispositifs renforcés de prise
en charge des sortants de prison pour
prévenir la désocialisation et pour
prévenir la réincarcération puisqu'on
sait qu'on a des taux de réincarcération
qui sont globalement importants mais
particulièrement important chez les
personnes porteuses de d'une pathologie
psychique c'est plus de 60 % de
réincarcération chez les malades mentaux
est-ce que c'est quand même on ne peut
pas dire que beaucoup de gens
qui sont en prison ne devraient pas être
en prison je
enfin une fois que la condamnation la
condamnation est prononcée c'est je
pense qu'il faut revoir les moyens de de
les moyens d'instruire ces dossiers en
amont de la condamnation pour
faire valoir
de la condamnation qu'on constate le
trouble mental ça pose un problème bien
sûr oui mais alors Marie jaccardie sur
cette question vous dans votre exercice
est-ce que vous avez constaté qui a plus
de violence chez les adolescents
aujourd'hui les adolescents qui sont
traités pour des troubles mentaux et
comment vous procédez dans ce cas là oui
alors je vais faire juste un pas de côté
parce que moi je vais centrer mon propos
sur votre question sur la violence
auto-infligée parce que c'est ça qui
fait le cœur de notre quotidien dans la
clinique actuelle avec
les malades se suicidaires de tentatives
de suicide les derniers chiffres que
j'ai lu c'est 25 morts par jour en
France par suicide et aux alentours de
700 te suicidaire grave et surtout chez
les jeunes et surtout chez les jeunes
c'est à dire les 11-25 ans
particulièrement les onze 17 ans et
maintenant nous voyons des enfants de 10
ans
avoir des conduites suicidaires en
exprimant une réelle intention de mourir
c'est ça qui a changé ça n'est plus
scénarisé comme avant comme une appel à
l'aide extérieure ça peut mais de plus
en plus les personnes expriment une
réelle souffrance dévastatrice avec une
réelle intention de mort et des
scénarios très précis pour ne pas se
rater donc nous nous gérons au quotidien
des cris suicidaires chez les jeunes
avec une inflation des passages aux
urgences environ de 30% pour des
passages à lactusidaires et ou des idées
suicidaires très scénarisées donc c'est
cela notre quotidien plus que les
violences hétéro agressives nous avons
une flambée des violences auto-agressive
qu'elles soient passage à suicidaire ou
geste auto-agressif tarification de
préciser ça à l'égard des
téléspectateurs ces passages à l'acte
est-ce qu'à votre avis ils sont liés
aux réseaux sociaux est-ce qu'ils ont
été particulièrement forts au moment du
covid
d'où vient que il y a faut le dire le
mot n'est pas très joli mais un certain
en sauvagement
qui pénalise nos jeunes générations en
même temps
donc durant le covid pendant le premier
confinement il y a une baisse nette de
passage d'urgence concernant les
passages à l'acte suicidaire
pendant le confinement parce qu'il y a
eu un effet de sidération en fait de
cette crise pandémique qui nous
rappelait que nous étions vulnérables et
mortels donc une effet de fédération une
recherche de solidarité et de partage
collectif mais après en effet avec la
durée de la crise sanitaire bien sûr les
passages à l'acte ont flambé alors vous
me posez la question des réseaux sociaux
les réseaux sociaux c'est à double
tranchant à la fois la personne qui
souffre psychiquement est très isolée
dans sa souffrance donc ça peut être
positif quand ça l'a relié à une
interactivité un partage des souffrances
l'impression de se sentir moins seul ça
c'est le bon aspect des réseaux sociaux
l'aspect nous qui nous préoccupe
autour des procédés de harcèlement qui
ne qui vont maintenant au-delà du temps
scolaire mais qui se continue sur les
réseaux sociaux avec des process
d'intimidation très graves d'une part et
d'autre part
la contagion de symptômes anxiaux
dépressif
et les comportements chez les
adolescents par
mimétisme qui crée donc
un collectif de souffrance et une
induite qui peut être inductible en fait
qui peut induire le trouble
anxiodépressif et quelque chose de
beaucoup plus dangereux encore c'est sur
certains réseaux Tik Tok en particulier
pour ne pas le citer mais bien obligé
parce que ça nous a rapporté pas
beaucoup de jeunes où il y a des
scénarisations de passage à l'acte avec
où on peut vous expliquer surtout
comment ne pas se rater comment tu tu as
des idées suicidaires je vais
t'expliquer comment ne pas te rater et
ça c'est très très grave il n'y a pas
assez à mon avis de contrôle public
là-dessus puisque nous on voit ça au
quotidien vraiment
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de cet
aggravation
de la situation des Français notamment
des jeunes générations est-ce que c'est
habituel qu'une crise en l'occurrence le
covid qui était une crise majeure
provoque autant
d'aggravation alors ce que vous avez dit
Madame c'est un phénomène c'est que dans
la première épisode ça a été l'inverse
comme pendant les périodes de guerre
de guerre on a beaucoup moins de
d'expression de la maladie mentale
une tentative de suicide la France a
toujours été un pays où on se suicide
beaucoup avec des très très fortes
variations régionales alors moi j'avais
regardé ça dans une région qui est chère
à mon cœur que la Bretagne et et on
n'explique pas que entre la partie
bretonnante de la Bretagne
et la partie galop comme on dit là il y
a des variations de taux de suicide qui
varie de 1 à 4 c'est-à-dire en gros on
est vilaine on se suicide comme en
France mais dans le Finistère on se
suicide 3 à 4 fois plus pour des raisons
qu'on n'explique pas et donc il y a des
variations et qui sont anciennes il y a
des variations culturelles moi je n'ai
pas de chiffres sur les jeunes
générations et sur cette cette violence
mais il est clair que en France ça ne va
pas bien qu'on a beaucoup de signes et
notamment effectivement cette activité
mais je voudrais juste avoir peut-être
que cette émission se termine évoquée un
problème qu'on n'a pas encore touché qui
est celui de l'autre côté
d'une vie c'est-à-dire celui de la des
problèmes psychiatriques des personnes
âgées parce que
est-ce que
une de mes grandes critiques en nombre
ministres de la santé notamment ceux il
y avait au 30 ans parce que on paye dans
la compétences aujourd'hui
c'est que ils n'ont pas vu les
conséquences du vieillissement de
génération du baby-boom
il y a trois âges importants en
politique sociale de la traite dont je
ne parlerai pas il y a 70 ans quel âge
moyen l'hôpital et il y a 83 à 85 ans
qui est l'âge d'entrer indépendance donc
quand vous regardez
or il y a une partie sentimentale
de la dépendance qui est très très la
prévalence et donc on va rentrer dans
une période 2030 donc le début de la
génération du baby-boom avec une demande
de soins psychiatrique il va être très
très forte pour les pour les personnes
âgées alors écoutez il nous reste peu de
temps je vais vous donner d'ailleurs la
parole
Monsieur Franck belligier je voudrais
que vous concluez sur sur ce point là le
tableau de la psychiatrie en France
n'est pas en bon état il est naufragé il
est massacré selon Monsieur Zagury
d'entendre ce que vient de dire Marie
jacquardi au niveau du terrain etc
est-ce qu'il faut une loi cadre
aujourd'hui pour réenchanter la
psychiatrie et redonner espoir sur une
santé mentale qui serait plus considérée
comme un déchet humain en quelque sorte
parce qu'on parle beaucoup de réformes
de réforme de réforme mais est-ce que là
c'est pas il y a pas une urgence alors
je vais commencer par un propos un peu
général puisque vous m'avez taquiné tout
à l'heure je si vous permettez je vais
vous taquiner à mon tour sur je suis
marin
et le naufrage
c'est quand on ne peut plus rien faire
sur un bateau et je pense que la
situation de la psychiatrie aujourd'hui
c'est tout le contraire
on a des vents défavorables et un avis
de tempête et il faut que tout le monde
soit sur le pont et je trouve qu'on a
aujourd'hui quand je dis c'est tout le
contraire c'est qu'on a une situation
assez inédite me semble-t-il
pour que la psychiatrie puisse répondre
à tous ces défis un engagement politique
et financier qui est tout à fait inédit
on n'a jamais eu un président de la
République qui nous a commandé des
assises qui est venu les conclure
on dit toujours ça
un nouveau président
le fait est que nous avons aujourd'hui
un programme de réforme qui se poursuit
dans le temps depuis 2018 je ne dis pas
qu'il a produit des effets qui
permettent de répondre à cette situation
mais je voulais aussi
donner les signes de vitalité je pense
que cet engagement politique est un
premier signe de vitalité je note après
deux tours de France un engagement à mon
avis assez nouveau aussi des
administrations des centralisées que
sont les agences régionales de santé et
pour animer les références en
paiementales le sujet est pris également
par les administrations régionales la
jeune génération qui montre qui dont la
voix commence à porter et qui a des
idées et veut faire valoir un petit peu
cette psychiatrie qu'elle veut porter
pour pour demain et on a l'habitude de
dire que la relève ne sera pas là mais
moi j'ai plein d'indicateurs qui me
laissent penser que la relève est là
alors oui ou non beaucoup de choses il y
a eu beaucoup de choses ces dernières
années depuis le lancement de cette
feuille de route
avec des manifestements c'est
insuffisant de répondre à votre question
avec des réformes en profondeur qui sont
en train de se déployer réformes du mode
de financement réforme des organisations
territoriales réforme des autorisations
des une incitation à l'innovation les
équipes mobiles les stratégies
intersectorielles je pense que ça part
un peu dans beaucoup de direction et je
ne sais pas si c'est une loi cadre qu'il
faut mais il faut un discours qui
réunifie l'ensemble de cette vision qui
l'explicite qui donne le sens de de
cette démarche et qui réactualise ses
grands principes qui ont été donnés par
la loi de secteur mais qui les mettent
au goût du jour d'aujourd'hui avec les
défis d'aujourd'hui parce que les
attentes ont changé parce que la société
a évolué et je voulais juste très peu de
temps sur la question des violences que
vous avez posé tout à l'heure
un sujet qui va falloir prendre en
considération de manière très très
importante c'est le sujet de la montée
des addictions et en particulier des
addictions chez les jeunes qui là pour
le coup sont pourvoyeuses de vieux merci
Monsieur bélier monsieur algory vous
êtes convaincu ou pas mais on a très peu
de temps et qu'est-ce que vous
proposeriez mais vraiment
désolé de vous poser cette question en
une minute mais voilà c'est important ce
que je viens de dire Franck Bellivier
nous sommes sortis d'un déni d'État moi
j'ai participé à une émission de
télévision avec Agnès Buzyn j'ai vu à
quel point elle était pas restée
longtemps ministre de la santé mais au
moins elle a fait sortir l'état du déni
ça me paraît extrêmement important alors
ce que je proposerai c'est la
suppression de la loi HPST qui est une
loi bureaucratique la suppression de la
loi de 2011 avec une loi en concertation
avec
les psychiatres et une loi cadre sur la
psychiatrie ça me paraît extrêmement
important pour
restaurer le lien entre le pays et sa
psychiatrie publique et donc c'est déjà
trois réformes et surtout surtout une
modification du rapport entre la gestion
et le soin parce que le drame dans ce
pays c'est qu'on a confié toutes les
reines du pouvoir
à la gestion à l'administration au
détriment des intelligences collectives
et de la créativité alors voilà vous
pourriez souffler ces trois réformes au
ministre de la Santé monsieur Bron ou
peut-être plus haut à Monsieur Macron
c'est à vous de le savoir merci Madame
merci messieurs d'avoir participé à
cette émission mais d'abord une
bibliographie je voudrais
rappeler Daniel zaguriq vous avez publié
comment massacre la française aux
éditions de l'Observatoire vous montrez
la dans cette dégradation qui s'est
faite dans le cours du temps et
notamment en impliquant les politiques
Jean de kervas Douai vous venez de
publier la santé à vif alors ça fait
plusieurs années vous que vous cherchez
à sauver le système de santé mais vous
n'êtes pas lassé de faire ce travail là
non parce que j'ai cherché un moyen de
l'expliquer de manière simple et de ne
pas écrire uniquement pour mes collègues
sociologues politologue universitaire
mais d'expliquer au grand public tout ça
a été compréhensible très bien alors une
critique de la psychiatrie de la
situation
Mathieu Bella scène et Rachel Knebel la
révolte de la psychiatrie aux éditions
de La Découverte c'est une critique de
notre modèle psychiatrique et je
voudrais signaler de
Bélier et Emmanuel haffen vous avez
publié actualités sur les maladies
dépressives Lavoisier chez Lavoisier
médecine est-ce que finalement vous avez
pas le sentiment monsieur bélier que le
mot dépression recouvre pour la
population l'ensemble des problèmes de
santé mentale
je pense quand même que on peut on peut
trouver des délimitations même si elles
ont été constées par ma collègue des
limitations entre des grands registres
de symptômes donc voilà les troubles de
l'humeur sont une vaste famille de
troubles et non non on peut pas résumer
la souffrance psychique à la dépression
même si le terme est polysémique et
employé dans le langage courant et il
recouvre souvent de des réalités
différentes merci Madame merci Monsieur
avant de nous quitter je voudrais
remercier l'équipe de LCP d'avoir permis
la réalisation pour cette émission et
vous laissez avec cette citation les
maladies de l'homme ne sont pas
seulement des limitations de son pouvoir
physique
ce sont des drames de son histoire à
votre avis c'est de qui
hein vous séchez pourtant c'est de
grands ancêtre
Georges campguilhem
[Musique]